the Clark County School District is
finalizing its reopening plans but
certain challenges at the moment make it
pretty tough to know how schools will
actually operate starting August 10th 8
news now reporter Kristen Drummond has
the latest on the issues and what
families can expect a lot of variables
at this point Sarah that we're working
through CCSD superintendent dr. hey-zeus
ja not revealing reopening options
during a virtual meeting but admits
various recommendations remain under
review how do we get kids on a bus how
do we get kids into school how do we
offer research questions that primarily
rely on the budget a challenge since the
state has not revealed the final numbers
we are running out of time
for us to be able to open up school
safely there's a lot of stress being put
on a lot of folks the district projects
a budget shortfall of roughly 38 million
dollars
dr. Jarrah says the district is planning
around that but if the number goes up so
we'll have to go back and make some
decisions and make some changes in
August and June July which is a little
bit problematic for us to be making
changes in making decisions and making
cuts then the recent CCSD survey shows
most parents and students want campuses
to reopen dr. Jarrah says the district
needs to consider CDC guidelines
following social distancing around
transportation that's going to be a
problem for us that the the cleaning of
our schools in between you know at the
end of the day before dr. Jarris
stresses health as well as safety of
students and staff remain a top priority
when considering plans he's also in
contact with other large urban school
districts to share reopening ideas
Kristen Drummond 8 News now so the
district plans to present reopen options
at the June 25th Board of Trustees
meeting the option selected will be sent
to the state for approval